alors quand vous êtes un fou des mots on
va vous faire une interview par les
djeunes alors on va voir peut-être ça
sera votre prochain dictionnaire est ce
que vous savez ce que veut dire qui fait
sa race aux cetc c'est l'équivalent de
sam bot non ouais voilà no soucy
ça veut dire no soucy bon no soucy au
fait lie la live c'est du style
oui d'accord c'est un peu dégueulasse de
trucs alors à perab c'est-à-dire père av
quand on dit d'un truc que ses paires av
bah c'est un peu périmées qua non si
jeudi pierre perret je suis grave
vénère ça veut dire quoi très énervé
c'est bien
on zigzague c'est quoi ce gain alors là
je vous signale c'est d'un dictionnaire
alors le tchi oui c'est ce que c'est le
shiv belge et touche pas à mon chum est
pas là mais quand vous trouvez toutes
vos idées alors c'est de l'ère bush y
avait une tasse pc quoi une tasse p bah
c'est tout sauf ma femme d'à coeur
un tête c'est ce que c'est un jet à
ouimet bon c'est pas mon truc c'est de
la balle c'est ce que ça veut dire quand
on dit c'est de la balle c'est de la
daube non non c'est de la balle c'est
super ça veut dire alors c'est de la
balle que l'extra balle même pierre
hanot la bourre entre avec eux tu chies
facile alors ça c'est mme ebadi jones a
baissé de largo est assez vieux ouais ça
fait parti très fort ça fait partie du
javanais matinée de verlan peut se faire
pépon ok ok baissé mais chez moi c'est
du matos je dispute un renfort même
temps
et si je vous dis caire tu déchire à ça
me fait vachement plaisir vous avez